yeah I think it's also the nature of
people who are really young like in
their late teens early 20s I feel like
what I've seen consistent is people who
are raised in certain environments who
don't have a lot of money you don't have
the means to survive necessarily they
sort of gravitate towards the easier way
to make money like a young girl could
gravitate towards a strip club or porn
or a young guy like you in his early 20s
if you were in the perfect environment
you were in Miami and there was cocaine
dealers everywhere that's a really easy
way to make money quick so a lot of
young people gravitate towards those you
know the quick money when they're
younger I think well I think is I don't
know if it's the quick money because
it's not easy money by no means but I
just think is survival you know survival
yeah people want to make you know
everybody wants to be raised right
nobody wants to be poor and especially
when in our Latino communities right in
the Latinos we look at soccer players
and there are idols right and you know
Ronaldo they make millions and millions
of dollars they're African American they
look around they look at all this
Michael Jordan they want to be like them
whatever that's why every kid wants to
be a rapper or we say but they're not
gonna be but every kid can be educated
and have unbelievable potential and
become a Ben Carson
well he can become a Barack Obama you
know or was the difference they were all
race poor you know different somebody
believed in them somebody invested in
them so my message to my color community
is instead of burning down our nation
let's go back and burn our communities
with education with love instead of
letting those kids kill over $125 per
LeBron James shoes do like LeBron James
go back and talk to those kids and help
those kids listen with the money you
make if you just spent twenty thirty
million dollar like LeBron you see you
don't have to sell the Ferrari you're
not to sell none of that trust me I know
you don't have to you could still gonna
leave a hell of a good life but you
ain't changed a lot of people's lives
right but what happens with our colored
communities you know Latinos and African
America was the first thing we do we get
the hell out and where do we go we go to
the white community
we have criticized our lives right you
know so we got to recreate our
communities so back to a social I guess
so yeah you were 21 years old and you
were 10 and and I worked for it I worked
very hard right because my father like
like I told him my father was a man very
proud would never take no money you know
and I delivered newspapers I cut grass I
was a father and a mother to my children
my brother his sister we had to take him
10 blocks to school come rain come shine
come
heat in Miami yeah and but it was the
greatest day so alive because we were
united as a family we were struggled
together I said well there's what people
struggled together they get closer
together
and I had a life plan planned I mean my
life was set in my mind the day three
days after came from Cuba my cousin
comes by and he has candy apple red GTO
convertible with white interior and I'm
like damn I never see some that Bureau
say the day I have that I would be
somebody so I was focused I'm gonna go
to school I'm gonna work I'm gonna get
out of college at 20 I'm gonna get out
of Law School
23:24 I'm gonna be a millionaire 30
that's my plan
it doesn't matter what at the age of 17
I become the youngest employee in the
future bank in Miami and I worked
full-time at the Federal Reserve Bank
and I went to your room at night full
time Wow I had no life for three and a
half years right no life I got up at
5:30 in the morning I was at the bank at
6:30 I got home at 3:45 four o'clock I
had my mother had dinner for me I'd be
school of five to ten I come home and
study to two o'clock and sleep three
hours and that's it that was my whole
life
because I graduate top of my class
because I always felt that the person
that comes in second place it's actually
the first loser so I did like to lose I
want the money back I will always want
to be first and then when I'm about to
graduate from us from Miami
now here's a kid I was if you look in
the dictionary at that time when I was
24 the word nerd it definitely had my
picture I mean I had braces glasses
I dress like a nerd I had I drove her an
old beat-up Chevy Vega with a big old
rust hole on the side and my County
professor asked me here moved from
Michigan and he was a partner passing
water health and then speaks Spanish
Mami's are they you wanna come work from
my office and if you come and just do my
Spanish clients I'll give your secretary
an office space you can start your own
business to me that was like the first
sign of God right because it's like
that's the other thing when I left at
10:00 in that airport in Miami I made a
decision got in real it's all [ __ ]
my mom is crazy because if we're going
to America to worship God freely and
we're going from wealth to poverty
where's God right like we do a lot of
time yeah so and I live my life like
that but never did I call all the
alcohol I did in my life by the age of
21 fit in a little teacup never smoked
never saw drugs in my life work
full-time I remember had this girlfriend
will go to a party and you know in the
70s it was everybody smoking marijuana
and uh and I smell it and I leave and
she's that we're not doing I said I
don't care I'm a federal employee I can
be around these people they're losers
I'm going somewhere in life I can't ruin
my career over nothing and that's how I
live and so I want to do the clients for
my professor and I'm like okay he said I
got this client was a look grocery store
you know and he says you bears $1,000 a
month now at that time I made big money
the further back I think minimum wage
was like maybe a dollar I was making 350
an hour
three and a half time minimum wage you
know I have a mid-level management
salary out I was living I thought it was
big so you know 350 an hour out I was
taking home behind when he bucks and
alls I'm like you paid a thousand to go
to this grocery store and do their books
for three hours every Monday man of
course is like oh I'm on my way so I go
there in the first and literally
literally it was about the width of this
room uh-huh
and about maybe like a little strip in a
strip shopping center right okay well
how those lose
stores and I go into the back office
nineteen seventy six and uh man I see a
grocery bag with $100,000 didn't think
nothing about it I'm like yeah it must
be since they never had an accountant or
never set up their books must be older
sales they haven't deposited them you
know here this is your job to count it
right well I would say I'm add
accounting I am sending up the whole
accounting okay I guys do the bank
deposits I got a pet do the pay rock I
do the whole deal honey sound Wow
so I left and think nothing about it
came back next week seventy-five
thousand now I start thinking you know
Wow
how can this store make so much
impossible the third week I go there is
another 110 and there's all the receipts
of what they have purchased for the
month and it added up to like I don't
know eight hundred to two thousand bucks
some of that and I'm like now I got
socks people so I called them in and I'm
like hey bro let me give you a small
accounting lesson in accounting we buy
something we buy that can of Campbell's
soups for one dollar and if we sell it
for three dollars
we got $2 profit now I've counted this
month over three hundred thousand
dollars that means that if you're making
triple on everything you sell you must
have spent a hundred thousand dollars to
buy all this right but all I see like
less than two thousand bucks doesn't
matter he went to the point never
thought nothing wrong yet and he laughs
and he's like we're not in the grocery
business with drug dealers are like holy
[ __ ] a drug dealer and I didn't even
know what the hell that was right
because in high school all we know about
you know kids took pills you know yeah
uppers and downers yeah I'm like what
and so imagine this frickin nerd all
summer and he said look George you work
for the federal government you know how
to open form bank accounts don't you
mm-hmm
I said yeah I do and he's like well how
much well I knew that it cost about
seven hundred bucks in green came in and
of course I don't want to get involved
in nothing I'm happy with my thousand
dollars a month you know and in three
other clients
making three grand a month doing the
Spanish class I was like in heaven and
he's and I'm like about ten thousand
dollars I want to give a number that
they'll just walk away he said you told
him it was ten thousand bucks yeah I
said because about ten thousand dollars
said okay we need you to open three I'm
like what
three damn so I left I acted like very
very serious and all that I said look I
can't travel for the next three or four
weeks a free ride and this is how much
time I need to figure who the hell I can
find we knew it because in the
fellowship bank we had busted in an
audit a bank this guy on three banks and
he had he had taken like three and a
half million of which in the 70s that's
like 50 million dollars and when that
note became do he'd have another Bank in
Grand Cayman number bank paid alone
right and he kept it like that for years
and the reason they got caught was when
the first bank went to order his
secretary would home the the Friday
early and she forgot to make the entry
was sitting on her desk and they come in
and that's the first thing they went to
look for they never I will never caught
it anyway so but I did and I went and
opened his bank account for me I was
like I thought was the richest man in
the world you know making I made like 27
grand and then one day he comes in he
tells me and this all happened within
six months you guys my partners would
like to talk to you they want to start
business and I'm like okay
[Laughter]